Steff you are an exuberant player but
the pouring out of emotion right as that
buzzer sound and what was the intensity
that was pouring out of you duodai
obviously and it wasn't pretty in the
second half but we've just made enough
plays clay hit some big shots the Marcus
gave us great minutes dream on obviously
doing what he does every night just got
to find a way we talked about going into
this game we know how to win one game
and then get back to the drawing board
obviously prayers under Katie he gave us
what he would he could and we hope that
he makes speedy recovery that's kind of
the mo of our team he he sacrificed his
body for us and I just feel bad for him
so well uh I got a lot of emotions right
now crazy
you were down six with about two minutes
ago you had been struggling the entire
second half so when you start to make
shots through those struggles is that
about resolve or trusting your process
what's that about just about keep
shootin I mean considering what we have
on the floor and it's the skill sets
that we have missed shots can't you know
kill your calm press the shots that we
know we can take so I know I'm gonna get
my legs ready for Game six and keep
shooting those same shots toward the end
of the last game you guys look
physically and mentally exhausted then
Kevin comes back and gives you a lift
and you get out of the gate strong you
have to absorb that loss so you know
what do you have left to give going back
to Oracle a whole lot I know our crowds
can be added to it
at this stage you know we know how hard
it is and how hard it's going to be to
come back and we gave our self a chance
so game 6 is gonna be fun go back to the
drawing board again it's gonna be a
dollar five or 48 minutes but we'll be
ready
six will be fine Thank You staff thank
you